the shooting Anna happened at an outlet
mall so an outdoor mall in the city of
Allen Texas it's a city of around 100
000 people in the Dallas Fort Worth
metropolitan area dash cam footage
that's been widely circulated online
shows a shooter stepping out of a
vehicle outside of that mall and
immediately start shooting at people on
the pavement more than two three dozen
apologies shots can be heard as this
vehicle recording the shooting drives
off authorities say seven people
including the shooter died at the scene
nine victims were taken to hospital but
two of them unfortunately died seven
people still being treated in hospital
as it happens an allen City police
officer was at the scene of this mall
that you can see on your screen now
attending and completely unrelated
incident they heard the shots being
fired and immediately according to the
authorities neutralized that threat but
unfortunately not before eight people
were killed in Witnesses report seeing
children among the victims the White
House say that President Biden has been
briefed on the shooting and the
Administration has offered support to
local officials this is the
199th mass shooting in the United States
this year a mass shooting defined as
when four or more people not including
the assailant are killed or injured are
quite staggering amount 199 mass
shootings in the United States this year
the Republican Texas governor Greg
Abbott he signed laws easing Firearms
restrictions even in the wake of
shootings at primary schools in Uvalde
Texas uh mall shooting and another mall
shooting in El Paso Texas he says this
is an unspeakable tragedy but it is
unlikely sadly to be the last